un violent orage fait rage dans le
quartier où habite jocelyn foudre frappe
tout près les maisons sont plongés dans
le noir
euh quand l'électricité revient jocelyn
réalise que cet ailier son ordinateur ne
fonctionne plus il fait alors venir un
électricien
ce dernier constate que ces appareils
ont été engrangés par une surtension
jocelyn à bell hydro québec pour
réclamer le remboursement de ces iem
mais une mauvaise surprise l'attend
hydro québec lui apprend qu'il ne sera
pas remboursée dans le contrat il est
bien indiqué qu'hydro québec n'est pas
responsable des dommages causés par une
variation de tension sauf en cas de
faute intentionnelle ou lourde
ici la surtension a été causée par la
nature je serai apprend aussi qu'il est
responsable de protéger ces appareils le
fin mot de l'histoire
s'il ya de l'électricité dans l'air
assurez vous que vos appareils sont
débranchés ou protéger